[Applaudissements]
lena clélia guillaume timothée son page
au centre de musique baroque de
versailles les pages ce sont les enfants
à partir de la sixième qui vont assurer
production et confère ils ont tous les 4
14 ans et sont élèves de troisième moi
personnellement j'étais assez petit
j'étais en cp avec ceux des faits ciel
de sa marge et mais je savais juste que
j'aimais chanter que ça me plaisait de
chanter quoi c'était mon frère qui était
d'abord au cmv et mes parents ont décidé
de m'inscrire aussi ce jour là ils
répètent sous la direction d'olivier
schneebeli le directeur musical et
pédagogique de la maîtrise le 21 février
et chanteront philippe hersant à radio
france
c'est vraiment de déjà de fonder
vraiment un groupe de fonder un groupe
et donc que chacun se sente responsable
au sein du groupe donc à différents
niveaux de responsabilité évidemment
j'ai pas avoir les mêmes exigences avec
des jeunes 6e qu'avec des grands
troisième avec ce
ce sentiment qu'on développe chez eux ça
ça mène à plus de plaisir ça mène à
moins compter le temps qu'on passe en
répétition voilà ils ont ils sont
toujours en soif d'être là de montrer
qu'ils savent faire
la maîtrise et en cham les classes à
horaires aménagés
le matin ils sont à l'école et au
collège l'après-midi cours de chant et
répétitions cmbv on va au collège de 8h
à 13h à 14h et puis on arrive au sommet
vais juste après on commence la
répétition
après généralement on a une pause d'une
demi heure et jusqu'à 17h 17h30 en
continu de la répétition
c'est peut-être 3 3 4 heures par jour
c'est comme des cours normaux donc s'il
fait un peu une sorte de petite troupe
vocale qui va se retrouver donc ici
quatre après midi par semaine les lundi
mardi jeudi et vendredi qui va leur
donner l'occasion de donner de très beau
concert à la chapelle royale du château
de versailles
mais aussi des tournées en france et à
l'étranger
les rendez vous à la chapelle royale ce
sont les jeudis musicaux 24 sont
organisées sur la saison 2018-2019 de
novembre à juin une dernière répétition
avant de se produire devant une salle
pleine
un moment de stress malgré l'habitude
les preuves sont là pour ça et entre
noja on a un petit jet ski et qui ne
souhaite bonne chance
moi j'étais stressée je peux 5e et 4e
mais après petit à petit on prend goût
et on s'habitue on va avoir un certain
nombre de publie un certain nombre de
personnes en face de nous un loisir
passion pour certains une volonté d'en
faire son métier plus tard pour d'autres
près de 60 enfants sont chaque année en
classe à horaires aménagés sur
versailles le recrutement débute au
niveau du ce1